[MUSIC PLAYING]
GERARD FERNANDEZ: I've been
playing games all my life.
It's my passion.
I also learned how
to program computers.
And then in 2001, we start
the first video games
company for mobile
phones [INAUDIBLE]
called talks Microjocs.
In 2015 my studio was
acquired by a big company.
Some of the guys and
myself, we decided
that we should do
something fresh,
something new, and we
found it Omnidrone.
"Titan Brawl" is a
real-time strategy game.
It's considered as a mobile.
Mobile is a massive
online battle arena,
but especially designed
for mobile devices.
The game is today
as it is, thanks
to the Early Access program.
We changed many things from the
learnings from the community.
Since we launched the
game on Early Access,
we got more than 2 million
installs on Android devices.
GONZALO FASANELLA: We started
in the Early Access program
back at the very
beginning of it.
The difference between
the Early Access program
and a traditional soft launch
is that users are actively
giving the team feedback.
So you don't only check
the metrics you have,
but they also provide
possible solutions.
So you end up by doing the
game players want to play.
The thing about
having the ratings
but do having the constructive
feedback was very good.
The Early Access was
a great opportunity
for an indie developer, someone
starting and [INAUDIBLE].
When we started with the
Early Access program,
we approached it in
different stages.
So the idea was,
at the beginning,
to focus on engagement
with the games.
Once we sorted that
out, we focused
on the retention of the game.
And finally, we focused
on monetization,
to do a valued product
for the market.
We managed with the
Early Access to improve
our retention in 41%,
the engagement by 50%,
and the monetization by
20% from the very beginning
of the program, till where
we launched the game.
GERARD FERNANDEZ: I
feel very happy working
on the video games industry,
because it has been
my passion since I was a child.
And it's really inspiring
that through Omnidrone we
have a real chance to shape
the new era of the video games.
ADAM GUTTERMAN:
Absolutely amazing--
hi, my name is Adam
Gutterman, and I'm
going to be leading
a panel today
about launching
successfully on Google Play.
That story about Omnidrone
just kind of confirms for me
that all developers
are dreamers.
They're trying to build an
experience, a world that they
envision here, up here in
their heads and their dreams.
And they're trying
to actualize it
through software and through
a mobile or whatever kind
of development environment.
And that's the challenge
of game development.
And it's not always
the easiest thing
to do to kind of
actualize those ideas,
and get them into
software, and get them
in front of users in a
way where you're really
communicating that artistic
idea that you want to put forth.
And that's why we
built Early Access.
It's one of the pillars
of launching on Play.
It's this safe sandbox
development environment where,
as you saw from the
guys at Omnidrone
when they were
developing "Titan Brawl,"
they were getting
great feedback.
They were able to
increase their metrics
and really communicate their
idea in a really beautiful way,
by the time they
launched on Play.
And they had a beautiful
game and a 4.7 rating
by the time the game came
out, all through Early Access.
We've actually got
150 games already
through the gate
of Early Access,
and we're continuing
to expand that program.
And the other program that
we're going to talk about today
is pre-registration Who here
was here for the keynote?
Yeah, a lot of you--
so you saw we've got some
beautiful games that we just
announced this morning, coming
through the pre-registration
program.
So please go to Play and
pre-register for those.
We've actually put
over 100 other games
already through the program,
and that's expanding.
Between those two
programs alone, we've
had over 60 million
players come through.
And it's been absolutely
phenomenal to see
the reaction of players playing
these games in Early Access
and giving feedback
to our developers,
players signing up to
be notified on day one,
on launch day, for when
their favorite games are
going to be coming out.
And these programs
continue to grow.
And if you're a
developer and you think
you've got a game that is
going to be ideal for one
of these programs, please reach
out to us here at Google Play,
and we can have that
conversation as well.
In the meanwhile, we're
going to bring out
some great people,
some people that I've
been working with for a
very, very long time in game
development, some people that
can talk about early access
and pre-registration a
lot better than I can,
because they actually
use these programs.
So welcome our panelists
out to the stage.
[APPLAUSE]
All right, so first things
first-- can you guys please
introduce yourselves?
AUTUMN BROWN: Sure-- hi,
everyone, I'm Autumn Brown.
I work at EA, and I run
our publishing team.
So I get to work with
all of our studios
and make sure they use awesome
tools like pre-registration.
SARAH MILLER: Hey,
I'm Sarah Miller.
I work at Nix Hydra Games,
which is a small indie-ish game
company.
We focus on building games
for young women, which
we view as a pretty
under-served audience
in the mobile
industry, currently.
JOE RAEBURN: Hi,
I'm Joe Raeburn.
I was a founding product
guy at Space Ape games.
It was a 15-person studio.
We launched "Samurai Siege"
and grew up to 100 people.
Right now I'm the product
owner on a new game.
It's a cart-racing game
that's in Early Access.
SHAUN RUTLAND: Hi, I'm Shaun
Rutland, the CEO of Hutch.
We are based in London
and Brighton in the UK.
We've got 50 staff.
We're super focused and
passionate about racing games
and re-imagining racing
games for mobile.
ADAM GUTTERMAN: All
right, since you both
mentioned racing
games, and you're
both kind of developing
in the same space,
and I think you
guys have both used
early access-- is that right?
Let's start there.
I think that's a
great place to start.
SHAUN RUTLAND:
Yeah, so last year
we had a great experience
using Early Access.
We've got a very
different take on racing.
Everyone thinks of racing as
a typical skill-based racing
game.
We've got two games
coming out this year.
One's a collectible car
trading racing game.
So we had no idea if this game
was going to work, resonate
with consumers.
And we used Early
Access to validate that.
And so the first
initial months, we
were getting some pretty
fascinating feedback
from players, a lot
around art style.
So I actually treat
Early Access a bit
different than soft launch,
which soft launch for us
is more about
optimization and making
sure that we can
optimize economies,
as well as device optimizations.
But what was really exciting
was the qualitative feedback
that was coming through
Early Access, which
led us to understand that
the way we were representing
our game needed to change.
And we changed it, and
day-one retention, I think,
went up, like, 15% because
we got 30% more people
through the tutorial, and
then day seven increased.
So to have a program that
you can use that can actually
really influence the very early
stages of your development--
I think that's really
powerful for developers.
ADAM GUTTERMAN: And you
mentioned you got feedback
on the art style.
That was something
you guys were testing.
SHAUN RUTLAND: Yeah, so because
it's a collectible car trading
game, it's going to get the
Guinness Book of Records
for having the most
licensed cars in a game.
So it's got about 2
and 1/2 thousand cars.
We're using photos for the cars,
but we represented those cars
as dots in a racetrack.
We thought that was pretty cool.
We thought that's a good idea,
because production-wise, we
don't want to model 2
and 1/2 thousand cars.
Players told us they
want to see cars.
So there's an
emotional disconnect.
And what we did was we
found a different way
to represent each car
in the game through 3D.
And we've never in the history--
in the last five
years that we've
been building these
games, we've never
seen an art style or
an art change that's
made an impact on retention.
But this made a huge impact.
So it was a really
big learning for us,
and it kind of changed
the culture in terms of,
you can never soft
launch earlier
or get the game out earlier.
You always want to do
things to the game.
But actually, you just
need to get the game out
there and start seeing if the
core principles of your game
are working.
ADAM GUTTERMAN: Great stuff.
JOE RAEBURN: Yeah,
it's similar for us.
Early Access means we can go out
to real players just earlier.
And when you've got a
game that's really risky--
like we want to make the
defining cart-racing game
on mobile--
lots of people have
tried, and there's
been some success previously.
But there's never been that
game that's defined the genre
and captured the attention
of millions of people.
And we thought
controls is an issue.
So we wanted to try something
totally different on controls.
We want to see how people
respond to the controls.
We put it out there,
and we thought, oh,
these controls that we've
got-- which is portrait,
and it's got an arrow, and
you kind of drag the back
of the car, a bit like a game
that you made previously--
SHAUN RUTLAND: Yeah,
I could feel it.
JOE RAEBURN: We thought,
these controls are awesome.
They work really, really well.
Put it out to players,
and turns out they
didn't work as well as
we hoped that they would.
And so we're like,
OK, we've got a couple
of other control methods.
Let's test them.
So we're completely
changing the way
that players interact
with the game.
And there's a
paradigm when you come
in-- is this an arena game?
Is this a game that you're
battling against other players
from day one, or is
there a gentle, more
linear introduction
into the game?
Is there going to be a map?
So we tested three
different control methods
and two different ways
of on-boarding players
into the game that could end
up being more chalk and cheese.
And we found that one
of those combinations
that we were testing--
one of those combinations meant
that we're getting an extra,
I don't know, 12%
day-one retention,
which is pretty nice.
And over Early
Access, in total, we
were able to move our
retention up significantly--
I think 60% higher
than where we started.
So Early Access is cool because
you can ask the big questions
and get real answers
from real players.
SHAUN RUTLAND: And it's
not just New Zealanders
that use Early Access as well.
JOE RAEBURN: Not just New
Zealanders living in London,
but it helps.
[LAUGHTER]
ADAM GUTTERMAN: New Zealanders
making racing games, fantastic.
Cool, well, thanks for that
insight about Early Access.
Let's move on to
pre-registration.
Sarah, you guys had a
really, really successful
pre-registration campaign, one
that kind of surprised everyone
here and maybe even
surprised you guys.
I don't know.
You want to tell us about it?
SARAH MILLER: Yeah, that's
really great to hear,
that it surprised everyone.
We were lucky.
We had a game that had gotten
really successful beforehand,
just sort of organically.
It's called "Egg Baby," and it
was just really, really popular
with young girls.
So we wanted to make a
better version of that,
because we felt like
they deserved it.
So while we were
in pre-registration
with the new game, "Egg," we
had about 300,000 to 400,000
monthly active
users in "Egg Baby."
So we were able to cross-promote
to the pre-registration page.
We ended up with 250,000
pre-registrations, which was
so helpful for us on day one.
I think that turned into
something like 40,000
day-one downloads, and that
was before we had started
any of our other marketing,
which was amazing for us
because when we
started our marketing,
it made it easier
for people to search,
people to see it in
the charts already.
So yeah, it definitely
really helped our launch.
ADAM GUTTERMAN: So you
just did straightforward
cross-promotion.
Did you use any other social
channels or CRM channels?
SARAH MILLER: Yeah, we had about
175 likes on Facebook, so--
175,000 likes on Facebook.
So we promoted it there as
well, linking to the Google Play
Store.
And yeah, it definitely helped.
ADAM GUTTERMAN:
Fantastic, that's awesome.
I know, Autumn, you guys have
been whales on the program.
You guys have done several very
successful, very large present
pre-registration
campaigns with us.
Can you share your experience?
AUTUMN BROWN: Sure,
anytime Google
is willing to feature
you, we will jump at that.
So we were very happy to hear.
The first time we used it--
we've run seven programs.
Our first one was "Need
for Speed, No Limits."
And we weren't quite sure how
to use it, but Google was great.
They walked us through it.
That one, we ran two weeks prior
to launch, and we were happy.
We didn't really have a
benchmark at that time
to see what success looked like.
But similar to what
Sarah mentioned,
we noticed that our week-one
installs were slightly higher
than we expected them to be.
And then we also noticed
that our top chart ranking
moved a little bit quicker.
And then also, keyword
search was something
that we would keep
an eye on at launch,
and it would take us a few
weeks to earn the cloud,
from the store, to show
up in certain keywords.
So having that
pre-registration, that wave
of people come in on
day one or day two,
seemed to really help that.
And then we've been using it.
Like I said, we've
run seven campaigns.
Our last one was "FIFA Mobile,"
which we launched this fall.
And that one, we did
a little different.
That one, we launched
several weeks
in advance of our
worldwide launch date,
and I think we were all really
happy with the results of that.
So we had more lead time with
that to talk about the launch
and what we were doing.
We also worked really
closely with the Play team
to provide regionalized assets.
So we made sure that the content
was relevant to that country.
And Google was great about
helping us get exposure
in each of those countries, over
the weeks leading up to launch.
And that was, by far, our most
successful pre-registration
campaign.
ADAM GUTTERMAN: That's awesome.
And you guys did kind of a
traditional reveal of "FIFA
Mobile," like at Gamescom?
AUTUMN BROWN: Yeah, exactly,
so we have a lot of history
with launching games.
So we have a bit of a playbook.
And it was nice to be able
to tap into that with this,
and it gave us an
action for players.
So a lot of us are making
free games these days,
and it's an impulse for
people to go and install.
When you tell them it's
coming a few weeks from now,
it's probably pretty easy
for them to forget it.
But it was nice
to be able to say,
you can actually take an action.
Go and pre-reg on
Google Play, and you'll
be notified when it launches.
So we did.
We folded that into
our Gamescom program,
and then throughout
the weeks leading up
to it, alongside the
Google Play support,
we did a lot of
social media support
to make sure that it
was a constant message
to our players.
ADAM GUTTERMAN: And it was
a pretty similar situation
that you saw with
"Need for Speed."
It was just like an
accelerated kind of experience.
AUTUMN BROWN: Very much
accelerated, yeah--
I think we've learned a
lot, each pre-reg we do.
Another big, key part
of the preregistration
is, of course, the offer
that you're promoting.
It's nice to be the first to
know when the game launches,
so that might be enough.
But we always also--
and I think it's
a Google Play best
practice to include
some sort of a
pre-registration offer,
so really making sure
that offer makes sense,
especially if somebody has
never played your game before.
So if it's a racing game, a car
is really easy to understand,
versus maybe a coin value.
So we spent a lot of time trying
to figure out what could make
sense to go along with that.
Sign up to be the first
to know, and you'll
get X, Y, Z on those
first couple days.
ADAM GUTTERMAN: It's interesting
you mention the "FIFA" launch.
That actually changed our
minds about the program
as well, because up until then,
we'd had anywhere from two
to four weeks of a lead time.
You guys had this proposal,
going live at Gamescom
and then launching
two months later.
And we saw that if you have
a very traditional marketing
lead up with solid beats
all the way through,
all the way through
launch, you could really
drive a consistent growth.
And even somewhat similarly,
but a little bit different,
we saw something similar
with "PvZ, Heroes,"
where you had a very long
pre-registration program.
But the velocity didn't
seem to slow down.
It seemed to continue
to go forward,
all the way through launch.
Can you tell us a little
bit more about that?
AUTUMN BROWN: Yeah, so
"Plants vs. Zombies, Heroes"
was another game that we did a
pre-registration campaign for.
That one was, I think,
almost close to two months.
And again, I think
a really key part
of that was Google
helping us keep
that message relevant and
front-and-center to players.
So I think around
that time, too,
Google had launched the
consistent merchandising
area in the store, which helps
players get used to finding
these pre-registered
games that are
available for pre-registration
or Early Access.
So I think it just helps
that visibility in the store
and keeping the game top of
mind, as we continue to fine
tune leading up to
world-wide launch.
ADAM GUTTERMAN:
Awesome, good to hear--
we've got a little
bit more time left.
We'll take some questions.
But real quick, I
just wanted to--
do you guys have
any random thoughts
that you wanted to
share about launching
on Play, just thoughts,
memories, best
practices, recommendations?
I think we can
take questions now.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ADAM GUTTERMAN: Yeah, so
there's a couple of mics
just right there in the aisles.
Just line up, and we'll
take them one at a time--
you over there?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] thanks
for having [INAUDIBLE].
ADAM GUTTERMAN:
I can't hear you.
Shout really loud
if it's not on.
AUDIENCE: All right, no worries.
Is
ADAM GUTTERMAN: There we go.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I guess I was
just too close, not a big deal.
Anyway, thanks for letting me
be up here and pick your brain.
I have a bit of a
food-for-thought question.
What are your thoughts, each
one of you, on challenges
you've faced on a
storefront like Google Play,
specifically on visibility?
And what do you think
community solutions
slash industry
solutions for visibility
on proprietary
storefronts would be like?
Sorry if it's a bit
of a loaded question.
JOE RAEBURN: You can go.
SARAH MILLER: All
right, so I think for us
because we're small, we did
a really clear accounting,
before we launched, of
what our assets were,
and what our strengths were,
and what we just couldn't do.
So we looked at
our previous games,
and we looked at our
social media following.
And we thought really hard about
how to reach those people first
and foremost.
And then outside of
that, we didn't have
a huge budget for acquisition.
So we were really careful about
picking the right keywords,
making a description,
testing out our icon
beforehand, and making sure
that at every step of the way,
users who would want
to find our game
would be able to
find our game, and it
would appeal to them at
every point in that process--
so just a really
careful accounting
of what your strengths and
your assets are beforehand,
for sure.
JOE RAEBURN: Yeah, the
other way you can do it
is see if your game appeals
to any form of non-game group.
I think there's a great
talk coming up later at GDC
around launching a game based
on the TV series "Vikings."
So "Vikings" obviously
has a rabid fan base
of people who like "Vikings."
Same with "The
Walking Dead" games--
you're able to tap into a
community that loves something.
And it might not be that you
have a big brand associated
with it, but say
there's a YouTuber
that you know that
really, really loves
talking about driving carts.
And you happen to
meet those people
and go like, we've
got this game.
What do you think of it?
Maybe they'll be
interested in chatting
with you about the game.
And a lot of the big-name
YouTubers at the moment
are being contacted by
everyone, so you can't just
rock up to a really
influential influencer who's
in the gaming scene.
But you might be able to say--
I've got a friend.
He's launching a Ready Computer.
He happens to know who one of
the most famous Ready drivers'
co-driver is, and
he's getting him
involved in the
development of his product.
And I think that
story holds true.
If there's a non-game
interest to it,
and you can get that person
involved and maybe even get
them into the game and make
them feel some ownership
of the game, then you can use
their natural marketing reach--
someone that other games
companies aren't touching,
because all of the
obvious ones are going
to be pretty well locked up.
And maybe their community that's
something slightly different--
your game has an appeal to them.
And you can genuinely give
that person some value,
because who doesn't want
to appear in a game?
It's like the
21st-century version
of appearing in a movie.
So you might be able to
do something like that,
or you might just be able
to have a really, really
cool icon.
[LAUGHTER]
SHAUN RUTLAND: Sorry if
this comes across wrong,
but maybe building a game that
doesn't rely on the store,
so a business that has a good
LTV, cost per acquisition
model, blah, blah, blah--
that's how we see it.
Store positioning is great.
We're very grateful
for Google's support,
but we're actually
building games that can
be commercially successful, so.
AUTUMN BROWN: Yeah, and
I guess just to echo,
leverage all the tools.
I think Google Play
does a really good job
of allowing us direct access to
the players in a lot of ways.
So icon testing was
mentioned up here.
That's huge.
For "Need for Speed, No Limits,"
we recently just did one.
I know we're not talking
about A/B testing,
but we did a hot-pink logo.
And everybody in the studio
was like, what is that?
Why are we putting
that out there?
That was so off brand, and it
was by far the best performer.
So it'll surprise you
what you find out.
Just leverage the tools, and
then speak to your players.
You have the ability
in the review
section of the store as well.
And having that
two-way conversation,
I think, really-- it just
helps bring a lot of things
to light that maybe
we don't consider.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
The second part of that
question was, how are you guys
individually valuing and
testing your penetration indexes
for being able to communicate
and appeal directly
to your core
demographic audience
that you've identified
in your research?
AUTUMN BROWN: Testing.
SARAH MILLER: Did you say
testing it specifically, or--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, like how
do you validate that?
How have you guys
validated that in the past?
SHAUN RUTLAND: So Early Access
is really good for that.
So when we were building this
collectible car trading racing
game--
which is coming out
in July, by the way--
we had a business hunch
and a gut instinct
that these players, that the
super-fans of these players
would come from a very
specific community.
So in Early Access, we started
testing user acquisition
to that community,
and it was validated.
So that's how we
typically use a space
or a service like Early Access.
JOE RAEBURN: Yeah, one of the
cool things about Early Access
is, if you're a player that
goes into the Early Access
and has a look at
featuring, you're
a particular type
of player, right?
You're looking
for something new.
And the language
around it when you're
downloading the
game-- it's like,
thanks for trying our
in-development game.
It is in Early Access,
and it could be unstable.
That means you can
put it out early.
It's really, really
nice badging.
But it's just the right
level of obtrusiveness
that we can still do user
acquisition through channels
that we know.
So we can go like, I want to
target these guys on AdWords.
I want to target these
guys on Facebook.
I want to target
these guys on YouTube.
You can just choose
what channel you want
and see how effective it is.
And bring those people
in, and then you
have information
around the demographics
of those guys as well.
And you see what channel
your game is resonating with.
What's your D1 on this
group versus that group?
So even though the group of
people who use Early Access
and seek out Early
Access might be
different from your
regular players,
the messaging is just
at the right point
that means you can still acquire
through traditional channels
and not really
see much of a hit,
versus acquiring on a
non-Early Access game.
AUDIENCE: OK, last
part, and I'm gone--
biggest challenge
with that, biggest
challenge with the
Google Play Store?
Go.
SARAH MILLER: Well, for us
we're using a lot of these tools
really early on.
So we just have to communicate a
lot with our contacts directly,
because some of the
stuff hasn't made its way
to be exposed to the
developer in the console yet.
So that's really exciting.
It's really great to
be able to use that.
But we do have to stay
in touch very regularly.
We had to email
our contact to make
sure we knew how many
pre-registrations we had,
which was fine.
That's not a huge deal, but
it was a small challenge.
AUTUMN BROWN: I'll probably get
in trouble, but China, I think,
would be one of our--
we have a lot of
players, and we'd
love to work with
Google to be there, so.
SHAUN RUTLAND: I'll
take that one too.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ADAM GUTTERMAN: Duly noted.
AUDIENCE: I've got a question
on Early Access, which
I've done kind of like a manual
Early Access in the past.
And I've got feedback, some
good feedback, some not so good.
I'm wondering if you had
any tips or best practices
for getting effective
feedback in Early Access.
JOE RAEBURN: So I guess you
get two channels, one of which
is the reviews that
you get from players.
And I find those really,
really useful in that it
helps make sense of
your analytics, which
is the other channel.
So I think your game
should be well instrumented
when it goes in.
So being a product
guy, I kind of
think doing an A/B test of
things that are really, really
radically different,
like should the game
be an arena-based game,
or should the game
be a map-based
game when you first
start playing it--
they're two completely
different pieces of content.
I think if you're relatively
early on in game development,
you should take the effort to
make both and see how it works,
if you have a feeling that
either of them should work.
I'm not saying you should
always hedge your bets.
But right at the
start, I think you
take advantage of this
early group and the fact
that they are early,
and they can radically
inform where your game goes--
not just, should the
font be Helvetica,
or should the font be
Comic Sans, but how should
you fundamentally
interact with this game?
I think you take the opportunity
to ask those questions
through A/B tests.
The other thing that you can do,
which is really, really nice,
is just have a button in your
game that's, Take a Survey.
One thing we wanted
to do, and I think
we will do for our
Early Access games
going forward, because I think
we're going to use it again,
is take a leaf out of Ubisoft's
book, where it's just like,
hey, rate this mission.
Rate-- what are you enjoying?
And have a little system to ask
just one or two questions that
might be top of our
mind, but within the app.
So you can get all the
unstructured feedback,
and that gives color
to you analytics.
You can run A/B
tests, and you can
see if you should take
the game in one direction
or not, or that
it doesn't matter
and that you just go with
your design instincts.
And you can directly ask
players in-game what they think,
and maybe that would
be a cool product
thing that Google could offer.
ADAM GUTTERMAN: Duly noted.
AUTUMN BROWN: Put
that on the list.
JOE RAEBURN: But don't
do that, because it'll
give us an edge when
we design and have it
in all of our games.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So I have a question.
I imagine a lot of
people in this audience
don't necessarily either have
a major studio behind them
or a previously successful
product with six figures
plus of installs.
How much data-- user
acquisitions is very expensive.
We did it with "NASCAR
Slots," and it was amazing
the costs it gets into.
So if you're small
and, obviously,
you're not going to
try and buy 100,000
installs with a reasonable
budget, how many installs
would you say is
enough to be viable?
Is 100 players playing your
game enough to work with, 1,000?
If you had a brand
new product, how much
would you expect
in, maybe, a budget?
Is $10,000 a joke?
Is that way more than
you need to spend?
Give us an idea of how
you would do it if you're
starting from no installs.
SHAUN RUTLAND: So
without our game,
I think we had 3,000 to 5,000
players for a couple of months.
And to answer the question
that was asked before,
we had some really
good social tools
that we could communicate
with these guys.
So you can actually
gain a lot of insight
that's qualitative and--
but yeah, I don't
think you need to get
100,000 players to start
getting decent data about what's
going on.
You won't learn
about monetization,
but you'll certainly
learn about retention.
JOE RAEBURN: Yeah,
it's to do with how
big your uptake group is.
One of the reasons you won't
learn about monetization
is if, say, 5% of your
players convert, and then--
what you really want to do
when comparing two groups
is get a population
size of about 200.
I know there's
precise statistics,
and you can do
statistical significance.
But you want to get an
uptake group of about 200.
And if only 5% of
people are converting,
that means that you
need 10,000 players.
However, if you're
looking at something
that's a little bit
different, and you
want to run a single
A/B test, normally
getting about 400 players
to have 200 in each group--
if those things are
significantly different,
and I said you shouldn't
be running A/B tests
against font type, running A/B
tests around really, really
big things.
There's an argument
that's been put forth
that says any A/B test that
you need 10,000 players to run
means you're not
testing bold enough,
and you're being pretty wussy
when it comes to the decisions
that you're making.
So if you can't find the answer
with 500 players for a single
test where there's just
two variations-- in fact,
we use a--
you probably need 600, because
you want 200 in each group.
I always do a null
control group to make sure
that there's nothing going wrong
with the A/B test distribution.
But yeah, about 600
players for a single test--
so if you want to run four
tests, you need about 2
and 1/2 thousand players
in order to run that.
So that's one way that
you could look at it.
But it's a pretty over-the-top
[INAUDIBLE] way to look at it.
AUDIENCE: Cool, thanks.
SARAH MILLER: Yeah, I'll echo--
600 is where my
benchmark is for when
I'm trying to decide whether
or not to move forward
with a feature, so same.
AUDIENCE: Great.
JOE RAEBURN: Nice.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: This question
is for Sarah Miller.
I actually had a question.
Since you said that you release
games with the target audience
being young girls, did you
have any audio techniques
that helped give you
advantages towards your game
in the marketing, towards
your marketing strategy?
Were there any audio
techniques that
gave you an upper hand
against any other people
out there in the industry?
SARAH MILLER: I wasn't directly
involved with the audio at all.
I believe that we ended
up outsourcing it.
Having great audio is good.
I do find that a
lot of players tend
to turn off their
audio on mobile,
so for the people
who turn it on,
it probably means a
lot to them, right?
But for the people
who have it off,
they're never going to hear it.
But yeah, I don't have any
specifics for you, sorry.
AUDIENCE: All right, thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my
name is [INAUDIBLE].
So I guess my question is,
with Google Early Access,
when you're such a
small studio, people
don't really know who you are.
You don't have a
budget for advertising.
Is that something that
is still a viable option
for smaller studios like mine?
ADAM GUTTERMAN: Yeah, well, we
actually have a permanent place
on Play for Early Access.
So if you're accepted
into the program,
there is a permanent collection.
It's a little pill right
below the highlights
or right below
the banners, where
anybody who's interested
in joining the Early Access
community from a
consumer side can
come in and see what's
available and then check it out.
And we actually-- the
program is designed
for developers of all sizes.
Developers of your
size, for sure,
have been taking advantage of
the program very, very well,
because, again, you kind
of have that problem
acquiring enough users to
be able to test your ideas.
This kind of permanent
place on the store
allows you to do that
acquisition naturally.
And we have that kind
of community that's
built in to get that for you.
And these guys have been
very helpful in saying,
you don't need a
massive community.
You don't need 25,000
users to test your ideas.
A few hundred will
actually do it for you.
AUDIENCE: OK, and
then I guess just
to follow up with that train of
thought-- so my game is around,
I want to say, between
90% to 95% done.
And would you say that
that's too late to start
the Early Access [INAUDIBLE]?
ADAM GUTTERMAN: I
don't think it's--
I think that you may not
necessarily be quite as done
as you think you are.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, that
kind of happens, so.
ADAM GUTTERMAN: Yeah, I don't
think it's ever too late.
AUDIENCE: All right, awesome.
Thank you so much
guys, appreciate it.
ADAM GUTTERMAN: Great,
so we actually have
time for one more question.
So that's going to be you,
and then we'll close up.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much.
So you said a couple of
words about the Early Access
on mobile.
I wonder if there
are any drawbacks
that you can say
about considering
using the Early Access instead
of just releasing the game.
JOE RAEBURN: So this
isn't a drawback,
but this is something
to be careful of.
If you have a game that
is going to have a--
that you know you have a
bunch of really rabid fans
about-- so we made three "Build
and Battle" games in a row
for our first ones.
And so we've got a
bunch of super users.
And when these guys
come into a game,
they just really go all out.
And we know-- we're
very, very careful
with this one specific group
of users, because when they get
in, the game needs to be right.
And they'll play it hard.
And if it isn't right,
they'll bounce out.
And so although these guys are
the ones who really, really
want to get access
to your game, we
don't want them to
have access until we've
had enough time to tweak it
and make it perfect for them.
But actually, Early
Access helps here,
because we've been able to
have a conversation where
we're like, guys, the
game's not in beta.
It's not that thing where
it's out in Australia or out
in the Netherlands,
where we always
provide you access because
you need to have early access.
We're testing it out
with this new program.
It's not beta.
We're going to give
you access when
it gets to beta, which
is the time that we
want these people to come in.
So it's actually allowed
our messaging to be better,
the whole Early Access thing.
It's a pre-beta phase that's
got a really nice name,
so you don't want to
play the game now.
It's going to be a
little bit crappy.
But that's the one thing
that I'd watch out for.
You don't want to take these
guys who are absolutely
going to love your game,
but they'll burn out on it.
And they'll turn out on
it if it's not perfect,
and deploy that missile
before you're ready.
AUDIENCE: OK, sure, so you say
just that if it's not really
an experimental game
play, just better
to go full release instead
of Early Access, right?
JOE RAEBURN: No, I mean for a
particular segment of users--
the ones that you
know will love--
when the game is complete,
you know that they'll love it.
And you know that
they'll stick with it,
like the users that
you can cross-promote,
the ones that are
within your network.
I don't think you
want to cross-promote
those guys in Early Access.
You want to bring in
people who can tell you
what's wrong about your game.
And if you happen to--
the uses that come in, because
you're being very experimental,
you might burn those guys.
You might change some
things that they don't like,
whereas with this group
of cross-promoted users,
I think just hold on
with your cross-promotion
until a little bit later.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you so much.
ADAM GUTTERMAN: That
about wraps up our panel
on launching successfully
on Google Play.
In just a couple
of moments, we're
going to bring my colleague
David Geffon up on stage
to talk about building
community and what
you can do with that on Play,
as well, and his panelists.
But thank you all for
coming to attend this panel.
And just, can we give our
panelists a round of applause?
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]